he's been causing chaos during
commercial breaks for over a decade but
there's so much more to All State
spokesman Dean Winters than selling
insurance from his near-death experience
to his extensive acting career this is
The Man Behind the Mayhem
Dean Winters came into acting relatively
late in life after knocking around
Europe for a few years in his late 20s
his brother Scott introduced him to New
York City acting coach William esper
Winters took a class with esper and
quickly caught the acting bucks
immersing himself in the downtown
theater scene of the early 1990s while
bartending to pay the bills when I was
20 years old I was homeless I didn't
have a career and I got dragged down to
meet an acting coach and he became my
mentor and he kind of got me into it in
a 2021 interview with backstage magazine
Winters recall it the grind of those
pre-cell phone pre-internet years
calling for auditions at the corner
Payphone and mailing out copies of his
head shot to agencies and theaters
around town even in those early
struggling days Winters was serious
about his crap and he expected the same
from those he worked with he recalled
one nightmare audition for a film that
he had spent days preparing for but did
not receive the same level of attention
from the film's director he elaborated I
was off book on five page is aligned
doing my best and this guy is in the
back on his phone texting and eating a
sandwich I remember taking my script and
throwing it at him hitting him in the
face I didn't get that one I have a lot
of integrity and I have a lot of loyalty
but if you're going to treat me like
that it's coming right back to you in
the form of a script at your head
during the 1995-96 TV season Dean
Winters had a recurring role as Tom
Moran's on NBC's acclaimed police drama
homicide life on the street he managed
to land the role thanks to his
friendship with homicide Creator Tom
fantana which began at a bar in the
Upper East Side at around two in the
morning the pair hit it off and Fontana
offered to ride a roll into the show for
winter but the actor passed as he
recalled to AV club I told him I wasn't
ready to be on TV yet because I was
still living downtown and doing theater
eventually though he relented when
Fontana moved on to create the Searing
prison drama Oz for HBO he wrote the
role of Ryan O'Reilly specifically for
Winters Winters isn't the only one in
his family with an oz connection his
brother Scott a fellow actor also
appeared in the show a third brother
Bradford Winters was on the odds writing
staff
Oz was a landmark show for HBO bold and
Theatrical while also punishingly real
it explored adult themes and
serialization in a way that television
never really had before with levels of
explicit language violence and nudity
that would be shocking even in an
R-rated film thanks to the Men's prison
setting the show was also a somewhat
Infamous Pioneer in the field of male
exposure and sexual violence on the
small screen its first full frontal
scene came in the fifth episode of
season one as Winters is Ryan O'Reilly
as a mental breakdown while being held
in solitary confinement it's something
that he seems at least a little proud of
I was the first male to ever be full
frontal nude on American television so I
kind of I kind of hold that that mantle
thank you very much that statistic isn't
entirely correct the 1989 Western
miniseries Lonesome Dove featured a
brief moment of exposure and in February
1997 NBC broadcast Schindler's List in
Prime Time uncensored and ad-free but
the spirit of the boast is true Oz was a
television Game Changer and it paved the
way for the next two plus Decades of
adult-oriented Storytelling many men
would Bear all on the show literally and
figuratively but Winters was undoubtedly
the first
as a Young Man Dean Winters wrote
himself an acting bucket list of all the
different kinds of projects He aimed to
perform in someday he told AV club I was
like I want to be in a horror film I
want to be in a western I want to be in
this I want to be in that one item
Winters can cross off that list he has
appeared in a horror movie he played a
sleazy businessman mourning his wife and
dealing with amnesia in the 2002 direct
to video release hail raiser hail Seeker
it wasn't necessarily a dream come true
however in fact Winters didn't have the
best time on set at all saying I took
that movie at the last minute I got to
Vancouver and if there were 120 scenes
in the movie I think I was in 116 and I
got sick like at the end of the first
read-through Winters wound up being
extremely ill for three weeks of the
four-week shoot but one bright spot was
that some of the film was shot in a real
psychiatric facility Winters admitted I
was having nightmares and seeing visions
in the hospital it was just bananas but
it was cool I got to work with Pinhead
which was a dream him come true
for viewers of the NBC sitcom 30 Rock
Dean Winters will always be Liz lemon's
arrogant sleazy beeper selling on again
off-again boyfriend Dennis Duffy Duffy's
mini quirks including his use of dummy
as a nickname for Liz made him a fan
favorite but he almost didn't get the
gig as Winters himself put it I went to
the audition for 30 Rock I walked in and
there was like 30 guys up there reading
for my wrong and they all they were the
funniest guys in New York City I'm not
going to mention any names but they were
all a bunch of funny guys my age faced
with that level of talented competition
Winters bolted later on his agent's
assistant called to ask how his audition
went Winters lied and said it went well
but the assistant called him out Winters
continued he said really that's
interesting because they're waiting for
you they said they haven't seen you yet
the agency also issued an ultimatum go
back to the audition where they'd drop
him as a client needless to say Winters
went back and he got the hilarious part
I'm in
when I grab on I do not let go like a
killer whale going nuts on his trainer
at SeaWorld in a way Dean Winters was
right to be intimidated by all the
comedic actors lining up to audition for
30 Rock it's easy to forget now but
Winters was not seen by many as a comedy
guy in the early 2000s his best known
roles at the time were Oz and Law and
Order SVU both of which featured
horrific assaults and murders 30 Rock
transformed his career and in the years
since Winters has fully given credit to
the show's Creator Tina Fey he told
backstage magazine in 2021 Tina is in my
top two favorite people in Hollywood
she's always been in my corner what was
originally meant to be a three-episode
Arc in the first season became a
recurring role as Bieber King Dennis
Duffy appeared in each of the show's
Seven Seasons since 30 Rock ended in
2013 Winters and Fey have remained in
each other's orbit in 2019 they reunited
for a pair of All-State ads promoting
the insurance company's Drive whites act
and Winters has made guest appearances
in the Fey produced comedies girls 5 Eva
and unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt he said of
his friend I'll do anything thanks for
Tina just to be part of a Tina Fey
production she knows the quality is
going to be good the actors are going to
be good everything is going to be good
you can't kick me out I got squatters
rights which is it you love me or you
got squatters right I don't see why
they're mutually exclusive
one morning in June 2009 Winters awoke
with a fever and stayed in bed all day
the next morning he still felt terrible
and noticed he turned gray so he went to
his doctor's office that's where he
collapsed an ambulance raced Winters to
Linux Hill hospital but on the way his
heart stopped for two and a half minutes
paramedics revived him and he wound up
spending three weeks in intensive care
to recover from a horrific bacterial
infection over the next year winter
spent a total of 95 days in the hospital
and endured 10 operations including the
amputation of two toes and half a thumb
as he developed gangrene during his
ordeal he was too sick to act for a year
but exactly one year and one day after
he almost died Winter's best known work
hit screens when Allstate launched its
Mr Mayhem campaign
Winters almost didn't make those famous
Mayhem ads first off after his medical
nightmare he had to relearn how to walk
he recalled to the Sioux City Journal I
was feeling sorry for myself I had lost
toes and half a thumb and the tip of my
nose fell off and this nurse took me to
the children's Burn Unit I saw these
eight kids with prosthetic legs playing
soccer and I thought that's it that's
the moment when I turned everything
around and decided to learn how to walk
again encouragement came from colleagues
and Dennis Leary cast Winters in Rescue
Me after that Allstate Insurance sought
him out to play Mayhem in its huge
commercial campaign but Winters
initially turned it down the actor joked
on huffpost's life when they offered me
the commercial I said no my smart ass
remark was that I became an actor so I
wouldn't have to put on a suit and sell
insurance and then my agent slapped me
around and said come on get real
the Leo Burnett advertising agency
conceived the Mayhem at and in 2011
Burnett Executive Vice President Nina
Abney told at age that one of their main
goals was to quote kick Flo's ass she
was speaking about All-State rival
progressives extremely popular
advertising mascot thanks in part to the
flow ads Allstate's market share had
dropped for two straight years the
previous ad campaign was pretty
unmemorable with actor Dennis Haysbert
calmly and seriously reminding TV
viewers of the importance of insurance
the Mayhem campaign reversed Allstate's
fortunes with Winter's character adding
an emphasis on value over price after
all Mayhem frequently belittles Cut Rate
Insurance and the fools who buy it
oh what a hit and if you have cut
in 2011 502 Americans were surveyed on
11 insurance company ad campaigns after
the Geico Gecko and progressives flow
Allstate had the most correctly
identified ads thanks to Mayhem
considering that the Geico and
Progressive characters had been seen on
TV for years and Mayhem had only been
around for months that proved to be some
remarkably quick setting brand awareness
an All-State commercial from March 2023
features Winters once again as Mayhem
taking the form of your highly
competitive older brother whose overly
aggressive basketball playing turns a
friendly pickup game into a potentially
costly repair job the other brother the
one whose garage gets wrecked is mostly
kept in the background as Mayhem Hogs
both the ball and the scene but it
didn't take long for fans to recognize
him as Winter's real-life brother and
former Oz and homicide co-star Scott
William Winter the two Winters Brothers
began their on-screen careers at around
the same time in the mid-1990s and Scott
has also played a share of cops and
criminals his most recognizable role may
just be one of his earliest Scott plays
the Harvard blowhard that gets shown up
by Matt Damon in the 1997 drama Good
Will Hunting how do you like their Maps
the scene and its instantly memorable
punchline was parodied four years later
in Kevin Smith's J and Silent Bob Strike
Back with Damon Ben Affleck and Winter's
all reprising their roles
shooting 30 second TV commercials is
Dean Winter's most widely known gig but
it leaves him more than enough time to
do lots of acting in movies and on TV
shows since the Mayhem campaign began in
2010 Winters has surfaced on sitcoms
like up all night as Will Arnett's
brother in Brooklyn Nine-Nine as a hot
shot detective known as the vulture he's
also appeared in divorce as a
foul-mouthed lawyer and unbreakable
Kimmy Schmidt as the voice of a rabbit
cop in a police drama called Bunny and
kitty in addition to his recurring roles
on 30 Rock rescue me and law order SVU
winter start in Battle Creek a
short-lived CBS crime dramedy co-created
by a Breaking Bad Creator Vince Gilligan
Winters has also appeared in films like
John Wick and the devil you know
[Music]